all right here it is
here's what we've been waiting for the
trailer here we go
i'm so excited for this
come on
looks like just oh
it's the redder
what's in it
love it love it love it all right here
we go
fear
is a tool
when that light hits the sky
it's not just a call
it's a warning
it's a warning
yeah
i've been trying to reach you
oh
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens dang
it's only going to get worse for you
take it easy sweetheart
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
there we go
oh
that's happening
[Music]
dick
oh yeah
oh
oh that's sick
oh man
oh
man
oh i am so excited for this movie it's
going to be insane this looks
so much different than the other
batman's that we've got which i think is
going to be a really really really good
thing batman is one of my all-time
favorite superheroes
um
i love batman and i think this movie is
going to be phenomenal but what did you
think about this please let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below uh
what are you most excited for about the
batman don't forget to subscribe to stay
up to date on the batman news and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof